[Music]
despite their many online battles ali
reza faruja and hikaru nakamura had
never contested a classical game that
changed in round three of the fide
candidates as ali reza opened with the
white pieces and won d4 hikaru responded
with the nimzo indian
[Music]
alireza revealed deep and dangerous
preparation as he used no time on the
clock to reach move 16 and sacrifice a
piece on g5 a sacrifice that received
the brilliant annotation from game
review
hikaru literally not caring about king
safety accepted
we've had a whoa we've had a full peace
sacrifice here that's exactly what i was
thinking about how well how do you deal
with the pin you have to play g5 after
e4 so your car went for this variation
and then uh alireza sacrifice simply
sacrificed the piece though the engine
claimed an eval of 0.00 the position was
incredibly sharp and treacherous for
hikaru he sank deep into thought
very deep into thought
[Music]
engine perfect defense led hikaru into a
difficult decision pursue a sharp line
where he would win an exchange or enter
a worse end game hikaru ultimately
selected the end game understandably not
wanting to defend what the engine said
was a completely equal position if he
only allowed ali reza for connected past
pawns
this position is absolutely amazing as
wild as it seems this is not outside of
the realm of possibility right because
how deep does ferocious prep go
everybody every single move that hikaru
played was
was the strongest in the position in the
end game alireza quickly created and
advanced connected past pawns on the
king side with pressure on the clock and
board mounting the commentators began to
believe that hikaru might be losing are
we moments away from perugia
getting his first victory at the
candidates another brilliant move sent
alireza's pawn all the way to the sixth
rank consuming the last of his time
hikaru got the rooks off the board and
targeted a scary position
he had calculated it to be a fortress
alireza got his connected past pawns all
the way to the sixth and seventh rank a
single move away from promotion then
hikaro played pawn to c3
and left the board
c3 look at that counter play i actually
wait and ricardo stood up from the board
like he
okay wait hold the phone everybody we
were anointing for ruja but something
has gone wrong here
alireza began thinking
and thinking
[Music]
shockingly there was no way through and
after using up an hour and a half
alireza rapidly blitzed out the finish
conceding the draw hikaru had used only
three minutes on the clock after his
critical pawn to c3 i'm flipping bone
blown away by hikaru nakamura in this
game the moment he played c3 elmira the
dude got up
he spent a total of maybe three minutes
at the board in the last two hours like
he knew it was a draw before stockfish
did
i know sometimes he can bluff or
whatever but everything about this has
said like he knew it was a draw for ruja
took an hour
kind of came to the same realization and
now we're about to see hikaru nakamura
hold against great preparation
from the youngest the youngest beast in
the field
this draw probably feels better than
most wins for hikaru as he faced down
truly fearsome prep and survived for ali
reza fans this game confirms the level
of dedication and preparation he has put
into this event if he continues to bring
opening pressure like this he is bound
to score his first win soon probably one
of the most
intense draws that i've ever seen
seriously yes this is an absolutely epic
button
you